[Music]  kelly ripa skips Wednesday's live with  Kelly and Michael the first show since  Michael Strahan announced he's moving  over to Good Morning America today it's  building it for Kelly and Ana Gasteyer  how you doing I'm great how are you I am  good I'm good I've been in the news  lately  I hear that et has learned that this was  not a plan to day off for Kelly a source  telling us quote she was blindsided by  the news that Michael was leaving after  yesterday's broadcast that source adds  that Kelly might actually take the rest  of the week off to cool down et sources  say there has been tension between Kelly  and Michael over the last four years as  well as between Michael and the show's  executive producer Michael Gelman now  Michael Strahan will stick with the show  for a few more months before moving to  GMA as for who will replace him we hear  Anderson Cooper and Neil Patrick Harris  are the frontrunners for the job  [Music]